bonjour à tous
ce que vous savez ce que c'est il s'agit
du mont imba donc c'est un mot qui se
trouve à la frontière de la guinée de la
côte d'ivoire en fait cette photo elle a
été prise par satellite
mais pas n'importe quel satellite si le
satellite spot 6 celle interne du
dernier satellite d'observation français
et au début de ma carrière dans
l'aérospatiale j'ai eu la chance de
participer à la conception de ce
satellite plus particulièrement sur la
partie des logiciels de commande central
son lancement il a eu lieu en 2012 et il
a eu lieu sur la côte sud est de l'inde
et ce jour là c'était un dimanche à 5
heures du matin heure française
le lancement était retransmis en temps
réel à airbus et toute l'équipe de
conception s'étaient réunis pour pour
assister au lancement
as tu es vraiment un jour très spécial
pour moi parce que c'est vraiment ce
jour là que je me suis rendu compte du
potentiel de l'observation aériennes et
de tout ce qu'ils étaient capables de
faire un satellite
ça c'est soit 6
c'est vrai c'est vraiment dingue ce que
sait capable de faire un satellite ça
vole à 800 kilomètres d'altitude
c'est à dire 80 fois plus qu'un avion de
ligne à 27 milles kilomètres heure
vitesse seuls trente fois plus qu'un
avion de ligne c'est capable de prendre
des photos de 60 kilomètres par 60 km
comme le monde dit mme bacon a vu tout à
l'heure mais est-ce que les satellites
sont vraiment capables de tout faire de
2013 à 2016 madagascar a connu une
énorme invasion de criquets ses 500
milliards de criques et qui ont envahi
tout le pays plonge en plus de 15
millions de personnes dans la famine et
c'était plus de 100 mille tonnes de
culture par jour qui étaient dévorés
c'est l'équivalent de 700 éléphants qui
sa charge ne s'acharnera jour après jour
sur les cultures 40 millions ont été
investis par l'iphone dans les campagnes
de pesticides par avion et par
hélicoptère
et vous savez quoi les satellites sont
totalement incapables de détecter les
départs d' invasion acridienne puisque
les criquets n'apparaissent pas sur les
satiristes sur les images satellitaires
comment est-ce qu'on peut être capable
de cartographier la terre entière en
continu sans pouvoir prévenir de ce
genre de risque
comment est-ce qu'on peut être capable
de cartographier des pays entiers
sans pouvoir sauver c'est toutes ces
personnes qui sont qui sont qui sont ici
sont tombés dans la famine est-ce qu'il
n'existerait pas des solutions
complémentaires
est-ce que les satellites ne serait pas
limitée par parleurs leur résolution qui
est trop basse et leur altitude trop
haute
je pense que les grands espaces peuvent
être gérées depuis le ciel de façon
durable et peu coûteuse
je pense qu'il est possible de
cartographier à basse altitude
mais à haute résolution de façon à faire
ce que les satellites ne sont pas
capables de faire une toute nouvelle
façon d'observer les grands espaces à la
fois simple et rentable ce qui
permettrait aux grandes entreprises aux
petites entreprises aux organisations
internationales ou destinés aux
institutions publiques ne pouvoir
cartographier par leurs propres moyens à
grande échelle
mais comment me direz vous par
l'utilisation de vecteurs aérien non
habiter autrement dit les drones mais
pas n'importe quel type de drones des
drones qui sont à la fois léger et
facilement transportable facilement
déployable totalement automatisée mais
aussi surtout capable de voler toute une
journée pour pouvoir cartographier des
milliers d'hectares et tout ça grâce à
l'utilisation d'énergies renouvelables
alors autant vous dire que quand on se
lance dans la conception de ce genre
d'engin il faut s'attendre a essuyé
plusieurs échecs
donc cette photo elle est vraiment
particulière pour moi puisque il s'agit
de la photo de du premier essai du
premier jour premier essai notre tout
premier prototype on avait travaillé
plus de six mois sur ce prototype donc
on avait acheté un avion du grand
commerce
on avait mille auto pilot dedans on
avait fait toute l'électronique toute la
partie télécommunications contrôle
logiciel au sol ont donc pendant six
mois on avait vraiment donner toute
notre énergie pour que ça marche et
enfin venez le jour venait le jour du
test donc avec tous avec tous mes amis
j'ai ggt j'ai trouvé un terrain et donc
on a on a décidé de faire les essais sur
ce terrain là donc là il ya tous mes
amis d'airbus
on a commencé à faire les premiers tests
dans le gouvernent
alors on electronic communications et à
vrai dire on n'était pas très très
serein sur l'issue de ce test larmes il
ya même un de mes amis qui a décidé
d'éloigner sont bien moins parce qu'il
était sûr que la vesle avion aller
cracher sur lui donc mais malgré tout on
a quand même décidé se jeter à l'eau et
je dois dire que l'expression se jeter à
l'eau colle parfaitement à la situation
étant donné que quand on a mis plein gaz
l'avion a fait de m accra et s'est
crashé dans une grosse flaque pour finir
en mille morceaux
ok six mois travail reggiani à néant
donc qu'est ce qu'on a fait dans ce
qu'on a décidé de faire c'est de tout
reprendre depuis le début cette fois ci
on est reparti sur un nouveau drone
totalement différent on a fait feuille
blanche on à redessiner entièrement le
fuselage on a trouvé du fournisseur pour
le fabriquer on à fabriquer nous-mêmes
l'est langres avant chaque nervures les
collants rouges ont en en toile ans elle
est donc en rajoutant encore toutes les
parties de électroniques et
informatiques et et a donc là vous voyez
encore une fois c'est le jour du premier
test grand moment six mois de travail
etc
et d'ailleurs je me rappelle que ce jour
là on avait on avait donc trouvé un
champ et l'agriculteur de ce champ nous
avez vu comme ça ont ils trouvé ça un
peu bizarre et une dont qui nous avait
menacé de nous tirer dessus ici si on
continue nous et c'est donc ce qu'on a
décidé de faire à partir de là bas c'est
de passer de continuer en fait donc on a
on à risquer notre vie pour pour la
science on va dire et donc du coup la
bonne nouvelle quand même c'est qu'on a
survécu comme pouvait le voir et aussi
que finalement ce drone il a volé il a
volé une minute trente avant de se
crasher lamentablement de puissantes des
centaines de mètres sur le sol néo de
finir lui aussi en mille morceaux
donc encore une fois encore une fois
c'est le deuxième échec six mois
travaillent beaucoup de déception et
c'est risquer notre vie donc là ce qu'on
décide de faire encore une fois c'est un
nouveau modèle on redessine le fuselage
on refait les normes et l'électronique
etc
à six mois de travail donc re bonne
nouvelle le drone vol et vol
correctement et en plus de ça on arrive
à mettre des cellules solaires
donc là sur cette photo par exemple fait
voir que ont fait les premiers essais au
sol air que le moteur tourne
correctement et c'est donc ces gros pas
en avant mais par contre on se rend
compte que malheureusement il n'y a pas
assez d'énergie solaire pour pouvoir
faire voler le drone entièrement et
c'est à force d'échecs
c'est à force de multiplier les essais
multiplier les crashs et multiplier bien
développé quelque part notre résilience
qu'un jour on a réussi à créer un drone
qui serait unique en son genre le 2
septembre 2016 il faisait vraiment un
temps radieux à toulouse on est basée à
toulouse donc 35 degrés gros soleil
donc on dit ce qu'on décide de faire
c'est on va en ville on va sortir
l'avion et on va faire les tests
d'endurance pour voir ce que ça donne
on sort l'avion va sur le terrain et
donc on le monte on le fait décoller il
commence à manoeuvrer de façon
automatique donc au fur et à mesure que
le vol se passe on se rend compte que le
niveau de batterie ne descend pas il
arrivait à maintenir son niveau de vols
uniquement grâce à l'énergie du soleil
et ce vol là il a duré six heures donc
le sbk de phoenix que nous
commercialisons actuellement et le drone
le plus léger et le plus endurant au
monde dans sa catégorie
il est tellement endurant qu'il est
capable de voler toute une journée
uniquement grâce à l'énergie solaire
pour pouvoir cartographier les milliers
d'hectares il est si léger qu'on est
capable de le jeter à la main ou de
transporter sur son double il est
capable de franchir plus de 300 km d'un
coût et de cartographie des milliers de
kilomètres carrés et cpo cette
possibilité de cartographier art 13
heroes et de résolution permettrait de
justement de prévenir des invasions de
criquets dont on a parlé tout à l'heure
donc en fait les invasions de criquets
c'est une application mais il y en a des
dizaines et des centaines d'applications
pour ce pour ce genre de produit mais
moi j'aimerais bien vous parlez de
seulement trois applications vraiment
importante
la première c'est les parcs naturels
en afrique il ya plus de 9000 espaces
protégés mais trois quarts de ces
espaces protégés sont mal gérées tous
les jours il ya des éclaireurs qui
doivent partir en brousse seul à la
rencontre de braconniers est qui et qui
risquent leur vie pour ça les espaces
sont totalement inaccessible des
hélicoptères coûte cher en carburant et
en personnel formé et quand on veut
faire du recensement de l'anim ou les
espaces sont tellement grand qu'on
n'arrive même pas à suivre les animaux
en fait des fois on on arrive à
constater des écarts de plus de 200%
entre les entre les mesures grâce à nos
drones les éclaireurs n'auraient plus à
risquer leur vie mais étant donné que
tout le travail d'éclairage se ferait
par le ciel de façon automatique tous
les espaces les plus inaccessibles pour
être couverts sans une goutte de
carburant pour pouvoir faire du
recensement écologique préserver et donc
protéger les espèces en voie de
disparition et toutes les données qui
sont qui sont en général récoltées au
sol par exemple les photos qui sont
prises et qui sont déclenchées au sol
automatiquement pour prendre pour
prendre les photos des groupes d'animaux
pourraient être récoltées depuis le ciel
depuis le drone donc sans avoir à partir
en expos durant l'expédition pendant des
jours pour pouvoir les récupérer
la deuxième application c'est
l'agriculture donc l'agriculture
africaine est en train de connaître une
vraie révolution
ce sont des groupes de fermi qui se
forme et qui se structure à
l'utilisation de nouvelles technologies
pour pouvoir booster leur production de
façon durable
il ne s'agit plus d'une agriculture les
fermiers lutte de façon solidaire pour
pouvoir survivre mais plutôt d'une
agriculture ou l'afrique veut faire à un
pays un business prospère capable de
nourrir la planète entière
il s'agit de créer de nouvelles
solutions en s'appuyant sur l'innovation
d'utiliser la science pour créer de
nouveaux modèles d'utiliser la
technologie un qui serait une
technologie qui serait à la fois peu
coûteuse mais extrêmement performante
oui d'accord ça c'est très beau mais
alors du coup les drones dans tout ça
comment ça s'inscrit dans cette vision
on va dire donc en fait quand on
quand on prend une photo comme celle là
elle va être constituée de rouge de vert
et de bleu sauf que lorsqu une plante
communique sur son niveau de santé elle
ne communique pas dans ce spectre de la
lumière
elle communique plus dans le proche
infrarouge donc en fait plus une plante
est en bonne santé
plus elle va rayonner dans le proche
infrarouge - et en bonne santé - elle
rayonnera dans le proche infrarouge
voilà pourquoi est ce que nous on
embarque des caméras bien spécial qu'on
appelle des caméras multispectrale
capable de cartographier non seulement
dans le visible mais aussi dans le
proche infrarouge et grâce à ça on est
capable de détecter le niveau de santé
des plantes et donc d'optimiser les
fertilisants d'optimiser tout ce qui est
pesticides donc de diminuer la quantité
de produits chimiques et donc
d'augmenter le rendement en afrique il
ya beaucoup de deux cultures d'ananas et
ses cultures sont victimes d'attaqués
fongiques
donc en fait c'est des champignons qui
se développe extrêmement rapidement et
qui sont capables de détail de détruire
une culture entière si on s'y prend pas
à temps et à vous l'aurez deviné les
satellites ne sont pas capables de le
détecter
parce que d'une il passe pas assez
rapidement et de deux leur résolution
n'est pas assez haute pour pouvoir pour
pré palm n'est pas assez précises pour
pouvoir détecter les anomalies mais
grâce à nos drones on serait capable de
cartographier des milliers d'hectares
encore une fois très rapidement très
souvent pour pour détecter très early
stage n'importe quel anomalies de type
attaques fongiques pour pouvoir
atteindre un pauvre intervenir à temps
et va sauver tout les toutes les
personnes qui s'occupent de ces chants
et dont les chants font la vie de ces
gens là font troisième application
donc c'est tout ce qui est fort estime
donc les forêts représentent 80% de
l'âme de notre biodiversité
c'est l'une des plus grandes richesses
de l'humanité une fournissent l'eau la
nourriture
le bois est donc c'est l'une des des
réfugiés les plus importants de la
biodiversité actuelle sur terre il ya
près d'un an 6 milliards de personnes
sur la planète qui dépendent directement
des forêts
pour pouvoir survivre et 60 millions
d'entre eux vivent quotidiennement dans
ces forêts pourtant les impacts de la
déforestation sont vraiment très
importants
c'est à peu près 13 millions d'hectares
chaque année qui sont abattues à des
fins non forestière donc quand je dis
non forestière c'est tout ce qu'ils
aménagements avec culture tout ce qui
est bon il tout ce qui est surtout
surtout aménagements donc en fait 13
millions d'hectares c'est un pays comme
la grèce ont donc c'est vraiment énorme
et 27000 27 mille espèces meurent chaque
année à cause de la déforestation et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
adopter un mode de gestion responsable
des forêts en prenant en compte tous les
éléments jeu économiques sociaux et
environnementaux
il faut que les exploitations
forestières respecte la dia bloggie de
la biodiversité les ressources en eau
les paysages les sols et il faut aussi
que ces expressions étaient souvent
tation pour est forestière permettent
donc à tous les personnes qui vivent sur
le site de pouvoir perdurer de façon
durable mais aussi ces personnes doivent
pouvoir profiter des retombées
économiques des installations et des
plans d'aménagement
alors nous les nous les fabricants de
drones comment est-ce qu'on peut aider
là dessus grâce à notre produit on
serait capable de cartographier des
milliers et des milliers d'hectares de
concessions forestières pour pouvoir
mieux reconnaître les essences c'est à
dire mieux reconnaître les arbres
pouvoir avoir une vision plus précise et
plus fine des grands territoires pour
pouvoir protéger la biodiversité les
écosystèmes et aussi protéger la
biodiversité tout en garantissant de
grandes performances économiques
cette année gartner a prévu qu'il y
aurait plus de 3 millions de drones qui
volerait au dessus de nos têtes et le
potentiel
je marchais du drone professionnelle
s'élève à +2 à plus de 127 milliards de
dollars
le drone constitue l'un des plus grands
tournants de l'aéronautique
et pour la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité on a mis des millions de
robots qui volent de façon autonome pour
améliorer notre vision du monde
nous ce qu'on veut offrir c'est la
possibilité de saisir cette opportunité
pour pouvoir résoudre des problèmes de
grande envergure sur de grandes surfaces
la connaissance de nos terres pas cela
par la maîtrise du ciel et nous pensons
qu'il est possible d'explorer de grands
espaces de façon durable et notre
mission c'est de pouvoir rendre tout ça
accessible au plus grand nombre
merci beaucoup